hi my name is Christina Jamie Noah
summer Devin and this is my story being
bullied on Facebook I'm asked a fan on
Instagram Facebook I just logged in and
I saw like the little orange thing
popped up and said oh you have one
comment I remember opening it I could
see the first couple of lines in it at
first I thought it was a joke maybe it
was a Drake and then I looked at it and
it was it was pretty serious
it said attention America terrorist
alert Osama bin Laden has come back to
life why don't you just go jump off a
cliff you ruined the name of summer with
your ugliness damn [ __ ] grow some
balls really [ __ ] original ass pirate
stop coming to school nobody likes you
you're an ugly [ __ ] everyone knows what
you do sleeping around with everyone I
know where you live kill yourself kill
yourself kill yourself kill yourself
kill yourself kill yourself kill
yourself kill yourself that feeling in
your stomach like it just drops I just
felt so worthless I didn't know whether
to tell my mom I didn't know what to do
I definitely started drifting from all
my peers and you know I would eat lunch
by myself
it just it ran my life I just saw the
words all the time I felt like it
wouldn't even make a difference if I
wasn't here I had to just make the
decision that I'm gonna completely
ignore these comments you're not the
problem
the bully is actually the problem don't
keep it to yourself
you should tell someone I look back and
it affected me then but now I'm just
happy where I am and everything's going
really well people have their own
opinions and it doesn't matter it
matters what you think about yourself if
people want to say those kind of
comments to me at all they should at
least have the nerve to say them to me
in person instead of hiding behind a
computer screen everyone was calling me
gay and they were saying it as such a
negative thing but I turned it into my
positive it was like by the way I'm gay
like yeah I mean I'm awesome and I can
just be Who I am I would definitely say
being positive is the only way to come
out of that situation I felt like I was
young
that was experiencing it knowing that
there was other people out there that
had experienced bullying it did make me
stronger you're not alone